excellent so how many of you know a lot
about the neural networks or a medium
amount of knowledge okay okay that's
good I have a fairly building up on like
a little bit of neural networks
background trying to put things in
perspective with new renaissance of what
now it's called deep learning I myself I
am research scientist at Google I
actually moved last week from Google
brain which is down the road to deep
mine which is in London so last week I
was in London and so I'm doubly
jet-lagged but hopefully still still
still all here and and yeah so a little
bit about myself and how I got into deep
learning I have a background in
mathematics and telecommunication
engineering from from Spain I'm from
Barcelona and I did masters at UCSD
my PhD at Berkeley but it really was
actually doing my internships at
Microsoft Research where I got to meet a
lot of the students by geoff hinton who
is a professor from toronto who is a
pioneer in neural networks and as a
result my thesis topic was actually like
in deep learning namely optimization and
recurrent neural networks and once I
finished from Berkeley I joined Google
brain and now very recently I moved to
deep mind which which are I and these
two groups definitely have neural
networks are kind of their driving force
in several ways I hope to communicate
today first and foremost though I would
say that a lot of what I'm going to talk
about is done with great collaborators
most of them at Google or have been at
Google brain it's been a great two years
for me to to learn and grow and of
course it was nice out of the PhD to to
sort of join a group where we're deep
learning was the driving force you might
know a bit about history about Google
great brain but actually it was I mean
and ruing who was who is a professor
here I believe still
was part of the initiator at Google back
in the day so I have to say that a lot
of the work I mean I'm presenting here
it's done in collaboration and it's of
course extremely important to
acknowledge those guys and many others
that are not here and so I hope to
convey maybe a little bit of deep
learning and my my own take on deep
learning so I'm gonna give a little bit
of an overview please if you have
questions if you're curious about
anything you can ask anything you know
throughout the talk let's keep it
informal and and so on then I'm gonna
dive into more of a technical aspects
that that is something that I've done a
lot of research on the last couple years
and and this is definitely sort of a new
paradigm that's sort of starting to
explode again after some recent advances
in computer vision namely recurrent
neural networks
to deal with sequences so it's quite
quite interesting and then if we have
time I'm gonna describe some of the new
paradigms which deal with memories and
attention mechanisms that you can add to
these neural networks that allow them to
be more and more closer to two computers
so you probably have seen some version
of this a slide where you know it's
basically saying yeah deep learning and
machine learning in fact are very hot
topics nowadays there's a lot of money
from big companies from startups lots of
lots of investing lots of you know from
finance to you know to medicine it's
sort of taking especially machine
learning rather than deep learning is
really like being used everywhere I
would say it's hard to not find
applications of machine learning or
places where it could be applied and
this is just simply showing sort of
Google Trends where you kind of see some
sort of maybe exponential grow on
machine learning queries and quite
correlated with deep learning and then
the previous hot thing was super vector
machine sort of was discarded by this
knife graph in 2012 which would make
sense which does that was the big image
net year for
convolutional neural networks so on that
on that note simply I like I'd like to
see deep learning not as something like
magic oh that solves AI and so on I
really have a very pragmatic view on
what deep learning is or rather
supervised learning and what it is it's
basically a mapping from an input to an
output and here the input would be an
image so a set of pixels which you could
think of a back door or a matrix and
given this image you want to classify
whether there's a cat or a dog and
you're given many pairs of examples
through supervision so through some
human laborers and with that you
essentially train these convolutional
neural network or neural network to fit
a function so more precisely we are
trying to find a mapping that goes from
X to Y as best as possible for a given
set training set of x and y pairs and we
do so by simply optimization and here is
where like distributed optimization and
systems come into role especially where
something that typically has been done
at Google brain so you define these
mapping f of X which can be a neuron
network or it could be also of course
that in your classifier or whatever you
want and you define a loss over this
function over the whole training set and
then you're set to find parameters of
this function f that money minimizes
this loss and this is almost all you
need to know so perhaps this is why
answering or understanding machine
learning is is sort of easy because this
is really almost all it is
except there's lots of tricks of course
and making things work is sometimes not
as as easy as just applying these
mindlessly and I think deep learning has
really been successful as sort of
fulfill this promise of I don't want to
know too much about the underlying X's
and Y's but I have sort of a generic
algorithm that allows me me to map all
sorts of modalities and interesting
signals input to output and deep
learning indeed has done quite well so
it is part of or currently mostly in
stay
of the art on several tasks some of
which I've been sort of involved or more
involved through because they're
involving sequences such as language
modeling machine translation or image
captioning but there's really a very
wide variety of applications where
neural networks seem to help push a
state of the art and that's why probably
this it's such a hot topic to to work on
but I think for for the most part even
though I have a speech recognition
background and the speech rep deep
learning revolution started actually
quite early in 2008 perhaps this was a
result that made the computer vision
community really believe in this
convolutional neural networks which is a
particular kind of neural networks and
this was done largely thanks to a data
set which was collected by faithfully at
all and others here at Stanford which
just basically had a bunch of images
with labels of objects that were present
in the image so here is an example and
by having a lot of images namely for
that for the classification task 1
million images thousand classes and a
thousand images for each class you would
want to train these f of X that maps
from X the image to one of these 1000
classes and one of the architectures
that did fairly well last year and also
this year with some modifications is
what people are call these inception
architecture which is essentially many
layers of computation I haven't quite
described what these layers are are
exactly but bear with me on that
this is just showing the input there on
the left very small that's the X and
then there's a bunch of layers that are
all differentiable so we can all compute
the gradients efficiently and at the end
we just predict one of these thousand
classes and now the winning architecture
this year I believe is this is plenty of
something layers and the winning is a
hundred fifty so really it's it's
getting a little out of control
invision I would say but you know
apparently I had some layers tuned a
little bit the architecture you get
better and better at classifying these
objects in fact it's getting at the
level where perhaps untrained or a human
that might get tired to classify objects
across a thousand might do even worse
than the current state of the art and
this must be updated because the new
result actually helps the error rate of
the previous best result which was last
year archive paper so does not it so the
2014 was the official result and 2015 is
as I said having that archived 2015 are
almost having the error rate so the
progress and the pace of papers out and
so on is is quite almost unbearable but
there's really like a lot of exciting
ideas and many people definitely working
on this field so it's it's fairly
exciting and then you know the the
bottom line is you can do fairly
difficult things like I don't even know
this flower but these flowers are I mean
I know they're flowers
but these neural networks give you some
sort of classification that's fairly
fine-grained and they kind of
statistically speaking do a reasonable
job whenever there's some doubt I mean
there's lots of objects in this image so
what should the network - in general
whatever it outputs is fairly accurate
and then whenever it makes mistakes they
happen to be within reason I mean that's
not a snake but it certainly looks like
one and I mean that's not a dog but you
know it looks like a dog at least and
and so the net result of all these which
is why perhaps large companies such as
Facebook or Google are interested is
that now you're able to do large amounts
of computation automatically on large
amounts of data at bay very cheaply in
sense basically just using a bunch of
computational resources so in google
photos for example you can do cool
things like look for pictures you have
taken on on the sea or even videos
without you needing to go
every picture that you take and
labelling them so that's a feature that
God lounged and key technology behind
this is obviously these neural nets or
convolutional neural nets that I was
describing and then you can even do some
other funkier classes like drawing or
the other and it fairly I mean it that's
kind of strange Giada but actually I
believe that's a real example from
someone in our group so I keep it there
I hope it's a real one and not you know
then you might have seen also like all
sorts of things so I think with the
amount of people in the field makes
really like surprising you know you get
surprising side effects because you have
this social network effect where like
people start trying all sorts of crazy
things so this is sort of an interesting
experiment which was done by several
groups but Alexander is actually also
googled not at Google brain but he's in
the computer vision team and you might
have seen this but essentially you can
take any picture and sort of let the
network imagine or rather you optimize
instead of just passing the the image
through the network you say I want to
have certain class at the output I'm
going to optimize with respect to the
input so you sort of reverse the
optimization problem instead of finding
the best parameters you find the best X
for a given Y and you initialize that X
with an image and then you get all sorts
of cool images that look like art and
and further some some some guys from
Europe took this further and did this
sort of merging base image which is a
picture you can take like that River
with all sorts of artistic styles and
here's sort of the way to do this is
also through a neural network that was
trained on image net and you just take
the base image and you say I want the
high level features of this network to
map to the to the real image but the low
level features that map more to the
filters and sort of the low frequency
information in the image to map to
whatever artistic style and then people
are doing now you know all sorts of
startups applications and and you can
run this yourself if you have GPU and
two minutes pretty much so it's not
something
we might want to do on every image we
ever take but it certainly is pretty
impressive the kind of results of
merging and and sort of the art in
neural networks this was something that
last year was kind of a surprise to me
that so many people got interested and
there were so many cool things out of
this and then more recently specifically
today as well but but last year there
there is some work on using neural
networks that again map inputs in this
case images from video games to outputs
which are how to move the joystick or
press buttons on Atari for example so so
last year more or less a year ago people
from deep mine had this very simple
model in sort of in describing it which
was I'm gonna give you a video game
please maximize the score and all I
allow you to see are the pixels and all
I allow you to do is touch these four
buttons for example in a tie and then
you train a neural network and through
some some technique called reinforcement
learning you just try to maximize the
score let the age and trained and
eventually it actually got in most games
superhuman of course these these games
are in some ways cheetah ball because
you can get zero reaction time whereas
humans can't and you know you then never
get tired and so on but it still it was
it was quite a cool accomplishment I
have a video that I can show but this is
online so probably skip it actually and
then today actually the there there was
a new paper by Deeb - well where they
attack of the different game namely go
so if you don't know go is sort of a
chess but fairly more complicated in
sort of brute force search aspect and
and again the system was a slightly more
complex than the one that played at our
game but a key component was a neural
network that took ago 19 by 19 board
which which can be seen as a black and
white image and from that board decided
where it would put the next piece
so that was part of the system there's
other components but that alone actually
gets you a fairly good go player and the
announcement was that they actually be
the best European player and there's
gonna be a game against the best player
in the world perhaps you can go in a
couple of months so if you're an
enthusiast of AI and an sort of heart
problems that have been around for a
while I suggest you read the the nature
paper and there's a lot of press
coverage about this as well so and and
again all the components here are neural
networks which are these very powerful
functions you can learn from from data
which is sort of the key so so then now
I've been talking about neural networks
so what are neural networks or at least
the modern version of them well a neural
network has this key component which is
the neuron and a neuron is essentially a
linear combination of inputs so it
basically a neuron has a bunch of inputs
it combines them with a weighted sum and
the weights are the parameters that you
will learn and it computes the output by
doing this weighted sum plus a
non-linearity and the non-linearity
historically was a sigmoid or
non-linearity now people use this sort
of rectified linear unit it's been
called but it's a half wave
rectification or whatever there's many
names for this thing and and that's it
so the nice thing as is that a single
neuron if you said the waiter properly
can actually compute the three basic
boolean operations so in a sense if you
have a network of these neurons you have
in some ways a general computer of
course how to set the weights is part
it's a big part of the problem but in
principle these neural networks are
quite powerful in that they can
represent lots of different functions of
course they can actually represent any
continuous functions there's theorems
for that if you have a single hidden
layer but the way I like to see it more
is love like representing boolean logic
that has these weights that are learned
so again to be specific at that
f of X is now a neural network that has
the X and of course the parameters W
those are these weights this that
defined the weighted sums in neural
networks and it's called deep learning
because and creatively so you just apply
over and over the same principle of
having neurons that take inputs and to
treat these as the next step and so on
so you essentially are composing a
function by so W 1 with the
non-linearity defines the function over
X you take that as the output you define
a our of W 2 that takes the input as
that and so on and as I was saying in
image net this actually goes up to like
150 layers and in recurrent neural Nets
as you see it also can be quite the
composition is applied several times so
that's sort of the more specific form of
the of this function and then as I said
you just train it so that it
approximates the true true targets and
to do so you define some sort of loss
which is a sort of estimate of for
example the distance between the target
and what you predict or the
cross-entropy or depends on the task
these these changes in reinforcement
learning for playing games actually the
loss is something which is a in like
like long horizon and so on but in the
end whatever loss you defined the
advantage is that you can very
efficiently compute gradients with
respect to the parameters W for lots of
given x and y pairs and this is where
you can kind of choose the optimization
algorithm that you please but generally
speaking stochastic gradient descent has
been fairly consistently being used and
successful at many of the applications
that we've tried and in stochastic
gradient descent essentially takes a
subset of the XY pairs that you're given
in this training set and you compute the
gradient which is now a noisy estimate
of the true loss and you update your
weights a little bit and you keep going
until you converge and so that sounds
simple but actually it's not because the
laws and that's probably why neural nets
became a little unpopular is very
complicated
non-convex function so so there's only
very few kinds of neural networks that
yield a cost that these convex namely
has a unique solution wherever you start
and so on so that's definitely a
challenge to solve the optimization
problem also nowadays we have lots of
data so we have many input-output
examples in text for example like if you
take Wikipedia and you want to learn
something on top of Wikipedia you you're
talking about billions of words so if
each example is a word you have a lot of
examples like this is 1 e to the 9 ok
and also W the weights this vector of
weights is actually quite large so
merely having millions of parameters to
learn is definitely very common nowadays
so you can forget about things like also
second order methods at least directly
applied because computing for example
the Hessian matrix would require you to
store a 1 million by 1 million matrix
which is quite substantial even with
today's standards computers nonetheless
there are some efforts on solving
optimization and so on but it turns out
that stochastic gradient descent works
quite well in practice and the reason of
this is as I said first firstly you have
a very small sample to compute gradients
that allow you to do progress without
computing a gradient over billions of
examples and secondly the chain rule
because in the end you have this
composition of many functions that are
all differentiable allows you to compute
gradients actually quite fast so the
computation of gradients if it was in
fact able that would make basically
training impossible and so here is just
a silly example of a one hidden layer
actually 0 hidden layer neural network
where x and y are just connected with a
weight matrix plaza buyers with the
non-linearity and as you can imagine you
can do chain rule at each stage to
compute derivatives more interestingly I
think is the fact that it turns out I
mean at least in practice you train
these networks and you sort of train
them again and almost all the times you
don't seem to be affected by non
convexity namely you start from a random
position you let the algorithm run
and you kind of get the same accuracy
the same level of precision regardless
of where you started from
so this catastrophic area where you
would have a local Optima that's really
bad seems to not hold very much in
practice at least nowadays with the size
of networks that we have of course
there's noise in the system like the
gravy ins and there's techniques that
regularize that add noise further noise
but there's also some interesting
theories that are coming up from
Montreal actually that seem to suggest
that in fact if if you have a very high
dimensional space local minima is not
going to be an issue anyways and of
course we're optimizing millions of
parameters so we definitely have an
optimization problem over high
dimensional space and in practice and
some some Theory especially from from
physics which deals with Gaussian
processes which is not quite the
surfaces we have seem to suggest that
most local minima are actually very
close to the global minima so who cares
anyways and indeed things work so to
recap and this is a slide I I steal from
Ilya we have these powerful models that
have these parameters that we somehow
know how to learn via this optimization
process and the models we are one - we
want models that we can learn from data
and that are very expressive and deep
neural networks happen to fall into this
sweet intersection of these two models
and so that's you know the view of why
also deep learning or deep neural
networks are the kind of right model to
use when you deal with machine learning
especially if you have lots of data
although there's some interesting work
also and very like small data sets and
so on but of course imagenet and these
data sets generally have lots of data
however this is not to be said like that
you cannot just take this as a black box
there's always some pain that's to be
had and these I mean the least is I
guess in a good way for researchers like
myself quite long so there's lots of
open sort of problems or annoyances
rather when you are a practitioner but
you have to sort
of big learning raids sizes of the
networks architectures what kind of
pre-processing techniques you want to
use so there's a lot of issues that you
have to deal with when in practice then
you go ahead and you try to solve a
problem with a neural network so it
really is not as good as it sounds and
and that's more like bridging to the
next part of the talk is mostly what
I've talked about these mappings from X
to Y where X and Y's are sort of fixed
objects like images and whether a binary
label that tells you if it's a cat or a
dog but what I'm very interested in so
especially because I have this speech
recognition background is in sequences
so how do you deal with recurrency and
sequences and first I have a barrier
I'll go quickly through these but it's
important because a lot of things I'm
gonna say about sequences regard is is
involving warts and so words are how do
you think of words as as a continuous
signal and I mean this this again has
been done over and over but it's been
renamed perhaps again recently with
these word embeddings which is to say
the way to input words into a neural
network is as simple as representing the
word as one hot encoding so if you have
a dictionary that has a hundred thousand
different words you literally take a
word and put a one in the position of
the vocabulary where that word occurs
and then you have this huge vector and
you can then convert it to these more
like amenable vectors like like that
you've seen it like X and so on be a
matrix multiply which is of course a
sparse so you'd never want to do the
matrix multiply but you have a big
matrix that let's say is a thousand by
so you have this vector that is very
sparse and then you have a huge matrix
these these matrix is actually I mean we
are actually preparing a submission for
ICML and these matrix right now has
about a billion parameters by itself
because we have a vocabulary of that's
eight hundred thousand words and then we
have a thousand
dimensional vector to represent every
word so do the multiplication it's 800
million parameters and by multiplying
and essentially the spazz multiplication
is speaking one of these thousand
dimensional vectors that correspond to
whichever word you want to represent and
even if you train very simple models
using these sparse representation of
words such as this was recently done by
Thomas McAuliffe who was at Google by
now at Facebook you can sort of predict
neighbors of so you take text and you
take two words that are close by and you
try to predict from the word chart a
word that surrounds the word sharp so in
this case ocean and you train a model
just to do that from this word input try
to predict a word that's the neighbor of
the input word and all you do is embed
these word sharks with this space
multiplication you train these on a
large corpus and then cool things start
happening like these vectors now each
word is a vector of let's say 200
dimensions have nearest neighbor and the
nearest neighbors happen to be somewhat
related I mean you have all kinds of
different shark and for cars you get out
of mobile and pick up track and so on
and further what this day's observing
the paper by the way this is very cool
but I don't think we found a use case
for these other than being cool but you
can actually take these vectors for all
these words and also do sort of basic
arithmetic so I can sort of take Queen -
King and that difference vector happens
to be similar than woman - man so these
these are kind of interesting properties
and they're sort of in the paper you can
see this all sorts of things that mean
if you take Paris - friends plus Italy
you get Rome and so on so there's
definitely it's kind of cool that this
happened with a very simple model it's
not very deep in this in this case so
deep wasn't in that paper but it still
was very nice and it sort of bridges
well how to incorporate words or to
think of words as vectors which then
allow you to do to use neural networks
so the other important bit
in dealing with sequences is
understanding how difficult would it be
to model sequences or probability
distribution over sequences naively so
imagine I all I want is model
probability distribution over sequences
of two words and I have 10,000 words in
my vocabulary so to do that I basically
if I was training what's called a bigram
model you would simply count the
occurrences of every pair of words and I
would store that count okay what that
means is I need to store 10,000 square
numbers in principle if all the pairs
could occur and as you can see as the
vocabulary grows and especially as the
length of the sequin grows this becomes
quite impossible statistic in a
statistical efficient sense so there is
fortunately another chain rule derived
from Bayes rule which says wait a second
don't just produce the proposition of
over pairs of words you can do that by
doing this conditional this chain rule
that that's exact so you can probably do
probability distribution of the second
word given the first word times the
probability of the first word and as a
result these two probability
distributions there that are factorized
are over 10k so you are doing 10k
decisions and then you do another 10k
decisions instead of 10 K times 10k and
in general the chain rule reads as
follows and it applies to any any
sequence length so this is great because
it allows us to put proper joint
probability distributions without any
sort of independence assumptions over
sequences now these are probably
decisions in general but how do we
implement this with neural networks so
to build this up very quickly and very
simply you can think of first modeling
diagrams as I said you could just
essentially take previous words say am
and the next word would be from and you
could learn a count model or a small
neural net if you want that maps from
that word to the next word
and that would be a pretty naive model
because it's assuming the words only
depend on the previous words you could
do that with a large corpus of text and
that's fine that's a very crappy
language model but it's also like fast
to Train and it's actually used in
several places but so you have these
neural networks that map YT minus 1 to
YT
but then to implement the actual chain
rule is almost immediate to see that all
we need is to add connectivity not only
from the input of the word T to the next
T plus 1 we have to add connectivity
across time in the following way and
this is clear too you can clearly see
that in that case to predict the word
Barcelona that prediction depends on not
only the word from but through
connectivities of neural networks
depends also from the word am i and then
the special token start of sentence
let's say so in a sense we've
implemented a neural network that
predict the next word given all the
previous words and that's actually
what's called a recurrent neural network
and it's it's it's a fairly good
language model this was known before
let's say the REE explosion of RNN
research that happened maybe a couple of
years ago so these days actually has
been around for the models themselves
actually were in the original
backpropagation paper so and and one of
the cool things is that I was mentioning
is if you train a 5 gram language model
with source smoothing techniques and so
on you get perplexities that are 774
perplexity is just a branching factor
more or less on every time I have to
decide on a new word what's how many
options do I have
what's my I kind of I am in doubt to
predict from the word I am from I will
kind of be in doubt amongst 70 words
right and the best you can do is one
word because then you know what word
comes next and Aaron ends or rather
these thankee name things Alice tiems
that I'll explain in a second actually
review
the perplexity from 74 options down to
30 so they are really good at modeling
language which of course has very long
time dependencies so a hidden Markov
model or a simple model would definitely
not do as well and then you can do
already things like sample these models
so despite the fact that the perplexity
is quite low and it actually is a state
of the art on a fairly this is a 1
billion work data set so it's very it's
a lot of data the samples you draw from
this model are actually good but also
you could probably distinguish these are
probably not human samples I mean the
last one for example some of the obese
people live five to eight years longer
than others that seems I mean the world
knowledge we have is probably if there's
a study that will say obvious people
maybe live actually not longer but but
shorter but nonetheless it's a one form
sentence that the model gives us if we
sample these joint probability space so
we can do all sorts of things with these
recurrent neural networks and so what
are these boxes that sort of connect
elements in the simplest case it is
almost as simple as the neural net I
show before so you read you have sort of
a state that comes from previous time
steps on an input and you have two
matrices that multiply these two vectors
remember the X's are words and they are
embedded in these two hundred
dimensional space say and the state
could be five hundred a thousand
dimensional depend depending on the on
the task that you have and so to compute
the current state there's this recurrent
equation that that's why it's called
recurrent neural networks that is a
fairly simple neural network and then
from from this state HT you can predict
then a probability distribution over
words and these w's there are learnable
parameters you feed the data set that
you're given and you get these these
very nice perplexities but it so happens
that there is a model or recurrent
neural net model that's much better
that's called Alice TM that stands from
long short-term memory and this was
introduced as usual or many years ago
it's not only now that people start
maybe paying more attention to it and it
just has a sort of fancier recurrent
equations that so
take a state in that case city and HT is
the state is two vectors and then it has
some sort of logic that computes the
next state given the previous state and
it has some sort of gating mechanism
that I'll intuitively explain hopefully
just in in the next life and one of the
cool things nowadays if you are I mean I
actually knew about this model in 2011
but it was sort of a pain to implement
the gradients for this model because
there's many parameters and you could
get confused in many places but nowadays
we have all these open source libraries
so there is almost a one-to-one mapping
between the actual equations and then
some Python code that will just give you
the gradients for free so you could just
define any sort of model you want and
then optimize given some data set so
it's it's very simple to define these
models with frameworks like Theon or
tensor flow or whatever else is there in
the open source world so that of course
makes many more people try these things
because it's relatively straightforward
to do so and just some intuition about
these STM's so so all I want you to note
is this part here which to the current
state at time T instead of doing that
matrix multiply and sigmoid all you do
is you have this forget gate ft times CT
minus 1 so that's sort of an integrator
that if the forget gate if this F was 1
or rather infinity I guess sigmoid of
infinity is 1 so to city you always are
adding city by minus 1 so you sort of
have this leaky integrator you always
add these states to yourself and what
this allows you to do is shortcut long
term dependencies so if I try to predict
that I speak Catalan and of course after
speak there's going to be only a certain
number of words that are possible like
languages and fast maybe and slow and so
on but if I had in my memory recorded
that I've said sometime in the past
maybe 20 or 30 words ago I said
Barcelona the now suddenly the
probability that I speak Catalan and not
any other language should increase but
that will only be carried if you
it can learn these long-term
dependencies and if you actually unroll
the equation over time for recurrent
neural net you will observe the thing
above which is quite difficult to
optimize because you have all these
nonlinearities times and you have this
wh the matrix that is the recurrent
matrix apply it over and over and over T
time steps and what happens when you if
you simplify this and you think of a
linear system if you have a matrix
multiplied by itself many times it
either explodes because the largest
eigenvalue is greater than one or it
goes to zero very quickly if the largest
eigenvalue is less than 1 so it poses a
very difficult problem to transmit
information in for T time steps where T
is large whereas these Alice tiems if
you unroll the equation and assuming the
forged gates
do not forget you actually get a fairly
simple straight forward connection
between the outputs and inputs that are
T time steps ago be a through like
basically one matrix multiply plus one
non-linearity so that's kind of why the
big deal on these Alice times that if
you read a little bit of literature you
see there or over everyone that uses
iron ends uses some sort of lsdm and
then okay so that's sort of basic iron N
and then what we worked on mostly two
years ago we started this idea of
mapping from sequences two sequences
instead of mapping from a fixed X
dimensional to Y dimensional so how to
do that will become clear in the next
slide but this light is largely updated
and note that all the dates are almost
2015 but there's been a large body of
work on applying this sequence to
sequence frame work now that's been
called sequence sequence to all sorts of
tasks where the inputs the outputs both
or neither well neither and wouldn't be
the case but at least one of them is a
sequence and so how would you do that
given what we know about recurrent
neural nets and that's the main idea
it's very simple superficially but it
actually surprised to us when we tried
this for machine translation it works
very well so
imagine I want to map a sequence to a
sequence let's say a bunch of French
words a sentence in French to the
corresponding sentence in English so I
just want to translate the sentence
literally well I know how to model
language in English language very well
with a recurrent neural net that is just
the right part there where I can predict
Z given Y X and beginning of sentence so
that works very well but now how could I
also sort of model the English condition
on being good English and also condition
on there's a sentence I want to
translate from and then the simple
solution was you add a recurrent neural
network that encodes the input sequence
it doesn't produce any output its
mission is to write to the hidden state
whatever is needed for it to then spit
out the correct translation into the
different language and the magic thing
here is that everything all the
parameters are randomly initialized so
we literally have the simplest almost
the simplest model you could imagine for
machine translation namely I will need
to have supervision so I need to have
pairs of sentences that are translation
of each other and after I am given that
I put a model that literally models the
probability distribution of I want to
maximize the profit dilution of the
correct English sentence given the input
French sentences and I again will run
stochastic business and pass a lot of
pairs of examples and see I hope for the
best basically so and and as I said
intuitively this hidden state is sort of
recording first it's reading sort of the
French sentence putting it in memory and
then decoding that that memory of the
French onto the hopefully correct
English translation and then a note a
little like technical note of training
versus inference so during training we
will be given the pairs of sentences so
we know what Y is and we know what X is
and then we just maximize the parameters
of this neural network but then once
we've trained the model and we are happy
with how it does in the training set
we need to do and a different task which
is I'm gonna be given the French words X
and I need to find the best possible
English translation for this given by my
model so I want to maximize y and this
of course is a sort of challenging
problem because you have many sequences
and doing it naively would be terrible
so what you end up doing is you do some
beam surgery stick which is to say you
predict the first word and you keep a
bunch of candidates of good first words
given by the model and then you try all
the first words as as input for the
second word prediction and you keep
doing that and it's very straightforward
thing to write I've never wrote a
decoder in my life and this was very
straightforward actually so and that
actually works quite well
so to recap and I think in this light is
more English to French instead of French
to English but never mind that we have a
model that takes any length sequence it
passes through this recurrent neural net
and it generates this vector from which
it will then decode hopefully onto
French and it turns out this actually
easy
I mean improves on most language pairs
over state-of-the-art which which I mean
machine translation is a fairly old NLP
task and it is in fact our results from
Stamford because this is tank who is a
student here who has an intern with us a
couple of years ago and also last year
and he just want a competition where I
guess as you mean to Stanford University
I guess so anyways the numbers look good
and so all the other systems or most of
the other systems are sort of phrase
based machine translation systems which
need the alignment between the words I
mean they need a lot of information and
they really have a lot of tweaks so the
fact that in kind of a relatively short
time span we were able to sort of
achieve very good results and
translation really made the community
and ourselves believe that this model
that map sequences to sequence was good
so then we tried all other things you
you might have seen these two but this
is sort of a different kind of mapping
where we want to caption an image so in
this case the input is not a sequence
but the output is a secret
and since we can do probability of
English given French to do captions very
unoriginal II so we try to think of it
as exactly the same way as translation
is so we will be given many pairs of
images and captions and we again will
fit a model that can map from the image
to English and in this case the input is
a very special sequence that is of
length 1 and it doesn't happen to be a
word it's actually an image but since we
have these very good models that
classify objects what we can do is take
features from these neural networks that
are trained to classify objects take
those features as a special word vector
if you want on which we conditioned to
produce things like a young girl is
asleep with a teddy bear or whatever the
human transcriber decided this this
image was like and luckily there was a
very cool dataset put together by
Microsoft actually and there was a
competition where you know people could
submit to server where the test data was
held in place and you could only submit
five times the other yadda so the
typical rules but basically there were
like I think 16 teams a lot of them
actually converge to use these recurrent
neural networks or some form of sequence
to sequence some other teams actually
used other techniques for example one
that's very different is MSR had this
entry which was nearest neighbor which
is sort of tell me which image is
closest to my training set and that's
gonna be the sentence that I captioned
this image with and that actually does
not too bad as you can see in the
ranking I only put the top eight so this
was great the result of automatic matrix
of quality were superior to human which
of course should make you very
suspicious and indeed the case was that
in the competition they had they asked a
bunch of Mechanical Turk graders for
whether they you know kind of the system
passed the Turing test and in that case
the two matrix on the right are the
human matrix which are the ones we
probably should care about and as you
can see even though there as there is
correlation between automatic matrix and
and sort of so to speak
human metrics humans happen to be much
better at being humans than all the
systems that participated so 0.6 points
versus fine two or so points that the
best systems were able to do is quite a
difference and so it's these problem is
largely and solved and but it was sort
of going beyond this mapping to a single
object so you could map to a sentence
and then I mean looking at at how the
model performs especially after tuning
all these hyper parameters that I was
mentioning this is the painful part of
neural networks the best model after the
paper submission and which we submitted
for the competition was much better even
though the initial model graciously gave
some answer that was somewhat related to
the image but in the end the same
architecture about tuning hyper
parameters and doing a little bit of
sort of search over the search space
that is neural networks yielded
something that was in some cases clearly
superior than than the initial model
however the initial model was way better
than most of the systems that were prior
to last year I must say as you saw like
lots of groups published on this task
and now they have actually moved to sort
of visual question answering or
describing videos instead of still
images in which sequence the sequence
clearly applies but nonetheless the
results superficially at least look
quite impressive in that Wow it seems
like the computer really got it of
course there's a lot of language
modeling going on too so if you detect
there's a train saying there is a train
on the tracks is probably a very good
sentence because it's very unlikely the
train is going to be flying around and
indeed if you present the train that's
flying around it's not going to work so
the priors are very important in this
model yes
same from all the different teams I
would say the models of the model sizes
which relate to how much you have to use
so our model was fairly small I would
say it was 500 that the hidden state was
500 dimension for example the Berkeley
model was had a thousand dimensions and
had three depths of layers so so their
model was bigger so so did what it
required more compute power typically
GPUs so so because of this data set is
relatively small overfitting is more of
an issue so actually maybe the
computational resources you use to
search over parameters but in the end
the model you end up with is fairly
small and quick to run these actually
can run I mean you can get a caption in
in less than a second for any image so
you could you could potentially use
these to you know to label things that
you have and so on
but in the computational power in
general for some model T is important
and for image net for example it it is
true that using so I think we now use
thirty-two GPUs in parallel to train and
it takes you know maybe two or three
days but if a student has only eight
GPUs well then it will take some more
days right but luckily most of the data
sets we use especially when we do
research are publicly available and not
that large so it's still manageable for
a grad student that has a bunch of GPUs
so another thing we tried which was kind
of more of a silly thing but it the
history of this is I I wondered whether
we could apply machine translation but
to translate from a question to an
answer so we had this this silly idea of
taking movie subtitles and essentially
try to predict the next conversation
turn given the previous conversations if
that makes sense and I mean the
experiment resulted on some some
interesting sort of let's say
conversations if you will that you could
have with a machine definitely very far
from anything that will you know would
pass the Turing test but it was very
straightforward to train these models I
didn't have to make a rule based system
that you know dealt with conversation
state and whether I said hi or know all
these was sort of given by a large set
of subtitles and namely all the
subtitles that were in some website open
subtitles that something I guess and in
in general it was sort of believable
that the model would give an interesting
answer and and this there's again this
is again sequence sequence and the cool
part is that somehow Google decided this
was nice enough that they actually there
is a product out there that you know
does the obvious thing which is given
some short email especially if you're on
your phone it it replies to your email
and it's using sort of the same the same
model that we did some earlier research
on so I mean the system just essentially
reads your email and decides first if it
should reply automatically or not with a
classifier and if it decides that it
should reply it will put some sort of
short replies like kind of not very
exciting but that you could just click
and immediately get the answer so so you
know this is sort of a cool example from
me that do from the initial research
paper to the applied research paper with
which was the conversation paper to then
something that we launched there was
quite a quick I would say quick and
there's a research blog post on that if
you're interested or you could try it on
your phone please don't send most me and
then I'm not going to explain much of
these except the fact that there is a
very challenging thing here if you
didn't realize yet is which is we need
to cram all the sentences that we read
or the sequence input rather into this
fixed dimensional vector so if we have a
very long input which we might if we
want to say read a book and summarize
the book now we are trying to read word
by word a whole book and hope that the
state will summarize the book so that is
a very almost impossible like to imagine
this would work
and one of the cool advances last year
was the addition of memory and at the
end or attention this has several names
and the brilliant idea is as follows is
instead of trying to put this ABCD into
these bugs and keep putting information
into it to then decode it
we will instead allow the model for as
it decodes words out go and take a look
at all the inputs it's in and by take a
look I mean do a memory read sort of
what you would do in a machine so now
ABC V instead of trying to put all the
information through these long boxes
here they are just kind of a memory so
you have these matrix which is number of
time inputs and of size whatever the
hidden state of that neuron recurrent
neural net is and then at the output you
say okay before I output X I will go to
all the inputs and see what what I want
to read from it and then bring it back
to the output decoder and use it to
maximally predict X and you do that I
just put that for X but you do you would
have this new Ornette being used over
and over every time you produce a new
output and the math is there's some
details on like position based attention
when where where you attend is position
based so it's the beginning or the end
and the thing that got introduced which
was cooler in my opinion was
content-based attention which is I don't
care where it is but let's say I want to
produce an animal because the next word
seems to be an animal please look for
animal-like things in the input whatever
they are and then what looks like an
animal you bring it and then you decide
which animal it is so you can do
computation so rather to have a single
vector doing all the memorization of the
input you distribute the memory across
these boxes and you allow through more
computation to read the whole memory so
that that's a very cool model and I'm
not going to say much more about this
and there was a related paper from both
did mine and and Facebook the first one
is called neuro 3 image
and the second is memory networks but
essentially the mechanism is sort of
easily described as a memory accessing
mechanism and then for machine
translation for example without any
supervision on alignments you can you
can see that the model is attending to
the word that is translating from and
cool things like these there was a paper
on again captioning where the word being
output also many times were focusing on
the output or on the region of the image
that was being output so a stop sign
it's focusing on the stop sign and trees
is focusing on everything but the
giraffe and so on and a paper that we
did with which kind of pushed the
envelope of what would be defined to be
same to do was to try to use these
mechanisms to solve algorithms so now my
supervision will be I'm gonna give you
points on the plane literally so I'm
gonna give a sequence of points and I'm
gonna give you also the solution of
certain properties of these points so
you could imagine traveling salesmen
problems so I'm gonna you know and be
hardly solve it and give you supervision
on pairs of input sequences namely the
points and output sequences namely the
vertices and can we train the same
models to learn sort of these functions
that I actually don't know how the
algorithms work or I would have a hard
time for me to design an algorithm to do
this in a reasonable amount of time and
so we tried this for several geometric
properties and the result is essentially
is that for like very moderate number of
cities namely maybe 50 cities the neural
network was able to sort of understand
the concept of minimum path given the
points and so typical errors there's not
many errors but typical errors would be
something like this where you can see I
think here there is some sort of error
where you don't go through the quite
shortest path but it kind of got this
idea that given the point it needs to
traverse them in some like optimal order
and it got that just from the data not
hard coding anything so that was kind of
cool and just to conclude I I think
there's many open problems that
many people could could contribute from
several fields and this is already
happening given the interest on just
machine learning in general really deep
learning is just the F you know part of
the story but you know there's I mean
there's here is a list it's there's lots
of open problems and supervised learning
optimization has bothered me for a for a
while and I unfortunately haven't worked
on it since I left Berkeley but you know
someday maybe and and you know it needs
lots of data so so you know for example
to learn to learn this concept of
shortest path we need it at least let's
say thousands or tens of thousands of
examples pairs of points and shortest
paths and I mean I can I can literally
show a human even without describing
input outputs and maybe the human will
get at least the concept of comebacks
halls are quite visual so like data
efficiency is definitely a problem
although you know very good research has
been going on on that and basically I
think that they come message the most
important from for my experience doing
research last two years is that
sequences have really become first-class
citizen so so now like there's a very
cool set of research where it's no
longer scary to have a sequences of
observation as the input or as the
output and we are even moving beyond
that I have myself done some work on
thinking about sets instead of sequences
because some of these models as you can
imagine for example the the TSP the
input is not a sequence of points even
though we read them one by one it's
really a set of points and so there's
there's all sorts of interesting aspects
of learning algorithms and sort of other
data structures that are interesting and
I want to emphasize that to me deep
learning is not AI it really is just a
mapping function that can do quite quite
cool things I would say but you know
it's it's sort of I guess if you do
search like like in the in the recent
paper of today where they combine deep
learning with search to solve go you
could mention well that that's sort of a
very hard task for from an AI
perspective
and deep-learning certainly helped nail
down or narrow down the search space
that would be massive if you were to
self go naively and with that I am happy
to take questions I think we have about
15 minutes left and this is mean
Halloween I don't usually wear dark
dresses but maybe I'll delete the
original picture so it's less clear what
I was doing here
anyways thank you very much thanks so
any questions thank you want to talk to
Rita student test testing the next
character given the previous ones that's
it okay like some likelihood match
humans I haven't seen any learning so
yeah so why am i wondering that myself
they applied so one question that would
be interesting for me to answer is how
was before a given data set like the one
that we trained this gigantic model on
what would be human performance for
example if they sound character stood
for sports okay to match it using
maximum okay
used to run a like pray one teletype
speed so matching human performance okay
well I guess people have already well I
that's cool I was actually wondering
myself I was asking some linguist at the
conference last last month about human
performance because I have these
perplexity of let's say 25 is that I
mean are humans I
because our not and it's not clear how
humans would doing this test because
it's sort of weird to have to give
probabilities right right right right
I think speech has the nice property
where the plumbing speech I guess is
that the function you learn is
deterministic
to a large extent whereas if I want to
if I ask you what's the probability of a
certain sentence and winters you don't
know right I mean you know kind of you
we know if it's about its sentence but
yeah so that's that's interesting I also
Chanin I'll definitely written that I
was I would take issue with that the
problem with speech is that you have a
naive audience thinks it's gonna use
these things and it doesn't see
important pathological cases with a lot
of these things that only the people who
work in speech oh yeah that's our that's
like the phrase how to recognize speech
and how to recognize how to wreck a nice
beach as an example the night the night
audience doesn't see that how difficult
that comparison and that's only within
one language the English might objective
but there's actually lots of examples of
that and it gets even tougher in the
non-english languages right yes the same
mistakes that people make yeah it does
see our speed make the same mistake
initially but analysis of the tool to
compare easily that's the big issue yes
that's the interesting part how stupid
or how smart
Harris machine mate don't forget that
the first that's a good Pierce with me
no the big problem is actually a lot of
the work initially was done it was
funded decades ago for all in one
language that most people are on
wherever it was basically Russian and
English and it was there's no interest
in general speech recognition
well that only that only came decades
later that's because Dartmouth's the
most it wasn't just DARPA
rest of the NSA and the other military
batteries ever connected question that
the Traveling Salesman immigrant certain
prospect getting a bound on the
inefficiency of the notion that way not
that that's that's a bothering point of
neuro networks that generally speaking
it's hard to quantify or sort of give
any assurances of correctness and
definitely in that case it's it's hard
to know whether you cannot prove
anything like it's one point five opt or
2.0 opt or or anything like that
everything is probabilistic and not I
mean it's it would be it would be quite
a I mean an advancement to actually be
able to say look I can guarantee you
with some probability you'll you'll get
an algorithm that's one point one
optimal but but a lot of these fields is
for some of course unfortunately quite
empirical right so you know that's I
mean I think in terms of a special
specifically in neural nets and learning
algorithms which I would say is
something that it is like again it kind
of piqued interest maybe six months ago
but but it was it has been attempted of
course in the past you know like if you
look more than a decade ago it's mostly
of you know the questions you typically
see is can we can we even do it and then
hopefully more deep questions will come
as we say well we want to make sure we
don't you know waste gas by doing the
most stupid path you could ever do to
deliver these goods or whatever if you
care about you know bounce and so on I I
would say yes yet yet you could
definitely combine these as an
aristocrat right and that's precisely
what they didn't go I mean there's so
many moves I'm gonna consider only the
top ten given
by a neural network and you know you
might then prove that you could improve
on an existing algorithm by using some
heuristic that is not designed by a
human but it's actually learned from
data that that I think is the first real
kind of impact we might see from these
learning algorithms it will not do it
end to end as we were we attempted to
just solve the problem from from scratch
I think it will be a matter of
integrating machine learning which again
it's also being done in some I believe
in 3sat and things like this to to to
like search algorithms or just
algorithms in general but it's it's a
good point and this is I think while
some saw some time ago neural nets were
not so popular because of lack of
understanding I guess what they really
implemented like yeah nothing I mean
envision I think this made it work some
progress there but yeah I mean you
analyze the optimal inputs and you know
this yeah well and it's not cumbersome
if it's not yeah sure yeah I mean it
over that yeah so sequencing perversions
you basically compute sequencing to a
state vector and this doesn't seem very
messy sort of honestly like that so that
that was a paper at NIST in 2014 what
what was the simplest modification we
could do to our code to go from
generating language to generating
language conditioned on a bunch of
things like in French words or English
words and and it turned out that if you
had a large enough state space and for
the language that we tried it it's
indeed that vector became you big enough
so that it could you know encode two or
three word sentence which needs to know
how to translate and that corpus in
particular has up to 70 or 80 word
length sentences but it breaks down
quickly in other cases and in that case
you need you need attention
yeah is the size of that a big space
inside so I assume that was that's part
of the bank yeah yeah okay so my other
question was just kind of related to
that is if you think about the further
expansion that sort of intention and
memory and that is very interesting but
that seems like that also would make the
training of that whole system much more
complicated than longer because you you
need to now not only train the forward
Network but you have to basically have
that Network decide what it wants to
kind of name past right and it's not
clear what's being connected in the past
well yeah so I have not I mean I didn't
explain it much neater what that memory
and I think the well it's very cool
about that is actually it's still a
feed-forward network so these memory
like if you actually implement the
computational graph of like computing
say a forward pass everything is still
differentiable and so the memory you
don't you don't do a search over what
places you want to read everything is
learned from data so these access
patterns that emerge from translation
you get these alignments that make sense
and for programs like the D rotary
machine paper had these sort of copying
that you could see how the Turing
machine was sort of writing to memory
and then reading from memory all these
patterns are learned in a feed-forward
fashion so so the there's no like
technical difference between no
attention and attention it's yeah yeah
you are drawing yes essentially says
it's then lastly the networks that
you're going to set up for a mean
earning and e increases the same so the
set of parameters is constant because
the attention mechanism has a matrix the
next like couple extra matrices that I
am NOT a function of the length of the
input but the complexity goes from o n2
o n square you probably speaking so in
sequence to sequence you read that words
and you are to then words let's say if
it's sort of the same
and if you have memory you input and
words and then to output the first word
you sort of need to go and do this
matrix multiply over and input symbols
and so on so the output becomes N
squared but the number of parameters
crucially actually does not depend on
the input length in this content-based
attention in the position based
attention than that that's why I like
the content-based attention in such a
leap I think in attention mechanisms it
does it that so let me I mean I can show
you the equations so it's essentially
like you have you have a vector a state
vector at the as you decode so here I'm
decoding I'm trying to predict Y from X
and there's this state vector of the
recurrent neural net V ok what attention
does is it computes D transpose times
the vectors that you encoded e I so
let's imagine you encoded a sequence of
length in this case in this example
length 4 ok so I have e 1 e 1 e 2 e 3 E
4 I have this let's say the input is I
am a cat ok so I have these four hidden
states from the recurrent neural network
that encoded okay and then I compute D
transpose times e I so there's no
parameters at all right so you take the
output state you multiply by the input
state for each of the input States
that's the part that Oh n right because
I we need to do for matrix world like
rather vector multiplies and I will get
numbers that are that I can normalize to
be from 0 to 1 and then these numbers
I'm gonna use them to read this e1 to e4
so in this case I decide I want to read
position number 3 with weight point 9 so
it's sort of a soft pointer if you win
if you will over all the inputs and if I
have instead of 4 input if I have 8
input still no parameters you can just
do the same equations you get an 8 long
vector
and you can still do the weighted sum
with these vector x the e 1 to e 8 you
get D Prime that's the readout from the
input and you're in business so I mean
it's I'm sorry it's not super clear from
from this but but it really crucially
does not depend on the length of course
now if you train with lengths up to a
hundred and a test time you decide to
test it on sequences of length 2,000 it
very likely will fail but there's some
amount of extrapolation these models can
do actually but you see you're at the
output you have a vector I'm gonna inner
product this with all the input vectors
however many they are and I'm gonna use
that result to compute a weighted sum to
reduce that to a single vector being a
read out from the inputs it's a way it's
a cool thing that it works and again
this is all like differentiable so it so
happens that the things we read for
example we we have paper on parsing that
it turns out that you need to build the
tree at the output and it the member the
attention mechanism was doing sorts
tracking like sub trees and so on and we
did not care what it did as long as it
did you know feed the training data in
relation to the total space of functions
that can be usefully feasibly calculated
or computed by this model yeah so I mean
there's a universal approximation
theorem to theorem that says basically
since the ground for saying that any
like with a back even layer neural
network you can approximate any any c1
function I forgot there's and there's as
long as the non-linearity is
monotonically increasing and this
there's some like and that's actually a
pre old result and then there's some
and attempts again to prove that going
beyond one hidden layer it actually is
helpful because you would we would say
oh one hidden layer is all I need to
approximate any function so why would I
care so there's you know Yahshua
specifically and and then people that
actually are trying to analyze random
networks have some interesting results
Sanjeev Arora being one of them so
there's there's a bunch of words ending
in actually theory on why depth matters
and the kind of functions they can
approximate on how if we efficient they
are doing so that's the point there's
like that's what I mean in practice it's
obvious it is it is useful in terms of
let's say statistical efficiency and so
on but the the paper I haven't read it
in carefully enough detail but there's a
paper from James Martin's
very recently that actually proves
there's certain functions that cannot be
learned with n but can be learned with n
plus 1 and so on so this I mean this
it's it's a sort of fascinating sub sub
area which you know in practice I'm not
sure how much we will learn but I hope
we will learn like how to initialize
things and other complicated annoying
conveyances from learning the deep or
deeper and deeper models
you